we're cooking up a storm on the pier one
patio right now you're gonna have to
bring some of that down to the studio
afterwards Jamie doesn't that look good
we're talking french toast with grilled
pineapple a little bit of shaved coconut
mmm and it's all because of a B sharp
from Abby's kitchen calm you are up
first off you got some great grilling
ideas but i also want to talk about
these cool coquina barbecuing sheets
yeah this is something I've never seen
and I'm mr. BBQ at my condo so I want to
learn more about this what's make what
makes it special well this is gonna
revolutionize how you grill this summer
because it is a nonstick cooking surface
that goes on the grill you cut it to fit
the right size the grill so that we have
a different sides barbecue so that way
you know you get exactly what you need I
just leave a little bit of space to
allow the air to circulate but this is
gonna make everything so much cleaner
and healthier for you I've got some
pineapple already started with a little
bit of honey on there and normally you
could imagine putting honey on the grill
really scraping that up and cleaning all
night long but with the with coquina you
just wipe it clean with a little warm
soapy water and it's literally good as
new it doesn't hold any flavors doesn't
hold any any odors so if you know if you
got a vegetarian in your group or
someone that doesn't want the meat
touching the vegetables you just wipe it
down even reversible it's good as new
you know I was gonna mention i live in a
big condo a lot of people use it and you
know talk about cross-contamination you
know some people don't want their fish
touching their meat um but also the fact
that you know sometimes the BBQ is left
a little bit messy and this is this is a
nice clean way to talk to you literally
it just sees a hell of a heck of a lot
of time I mean we've got some coconut
going down here and I'm gonna toast this
up you probably have never seen coconut
done on a grill before uh but with the
coquina obviously you can you don't need
to worry about things going down the
grades I even find when i'm doing
vegetables I lose half of them down the
grade right so this way you just keep
everything intact and its really really
easy cleanup and the other nice thing is
you can smell it right
this also prevents those flare-ups I
know I hate getting those those the
flare-ups that cause the charring and
the trying to be carcinogens and so the
nice thing about this is it really cuts
down and any of those carcinogens and
you've got a bunch of recipes on your
website at Abby's kitchen calm and these
grilling sheets they're these look
awesome I mean we want to hook up our
viewers with some so we've got this
awesome gift up pack it's worth about
300 bucks and all you gotta do is email
us at contest at cp24 dot-com three
things that you would cook on one of
these grilling sheets it could be
anything email us and the winner is
gonna walk away with an awesome prize
pack and I think we're going to just
cook away as we go yeah right still get
the grill marks too there you go thank
you so much thank you to meet you I be
appreciated once again go check out her
website Abby's kitchen dot-com your
watches TV 24 breakfast weekend and I
think it's time to eat some breakfast
you to stick around we got more show
coming up at the top of the [ __ ]
next